Caching the photos is great, but
like we saw with the database earlier,
we can't just keep adding stuff.
We need to remove stuff
that we don't need anymore.
This involves a couple of cache
methods that we haven't seen yet.
If we want to remove specific entries
from the cache, we can use cache.delete,
passing in the URL or the request
of the thing we want to delete.
There's also cache.keys.
That returns a promise that gives us all
the requests for entries in the cache.
What I haven't mentioned so far,
is all of this is available from
pages as well as service workers.
In the next chapter, we'll use these
methods to clean the image cache.